All right. The question is why young people follow ideals that do not lead to resonance?
They have no value system.
The island of temptation is a good example.
The children brought to the island are lost.
There is nowhere to go. They have no identity.
That is why they turn to local pleasures.
And that's better than nothing. But, the problem of local pleasure,
at least according to the fairy tale, well, be careful if you are impulsive.
Because otherwise it will hit you hard.
And the reason is,
that you are looking only for a period of time.
And the problem is that things multiply between all the times.
Just because something works well at this point,
cocaine, for example ...
It does not mean that it is a suitable solution for the section of all problems.
That's why people often follow
local pleasure, because this is their best idea, because they are taught.
They see no other alternative.
They may be ignorant or simply do not want to take responsibility.
Because part of the problem with
work at all levels of the hierarchy simultaneously,
is like dancing a very complicated waltz.
You have to pay attention to many things at once and do everything right.
That is why responsibility is required.
And that's it...
pain.
Weight is one of the reasons people drink alcohol is to withdraw from their responsibilities.
You hear people say they drink because they have problems.
"It is so." Is not.
Some people drink because they worry
and alcoholics drink because they are in abstinence.
But young people drink because they are shaken by their responsibility.
Because it's annoying. I'm going to get drunk and I will not care about the close and not so close consequences,
because that's what makes alcohol.
Do not blind you to these close and not so close consequences,
but it makes you do not care.
And partly because it reduces anxiety.
So it reduces anxiety and keeps the emotional center intact,
so you can go out and do stupid and fun things.
This is the party real. Let's do stupid and fun things.
This is a party.
But ...
The near and less immediate consequences are ...
It's scared.
It does not mean you do not have to do it, but it is risky.
They do not know a better alternative.
That's what I would say is my answer.